I hate the fact that
us as black people we're out here
killing each other that's right
for what I don't know why come on Mom we
have the police killing us
that's right I don't know why
I just don't understand
why we have to have all this violence
and everybody have to kill each other
I mean what happened to this world
everybody want to kill each other nobody
don't want to talk to people each other
anymore what happened to the humanity
and kindness that's right amen what
happened to it all amen
but I just want to say
I want everybody to thank you guys for
coming
and we're going to get Justice for my
son Tyree
if that's the last breath I take that's
right amen because at the end of the day
my son and your son deserves this
at all